when the sun rises over lake malawi
africa's third largest lake it usually
means early morning chores have to be
done out here washing dishes and doing
the laundry is generally a job for young
women and girls when they finish some of
them will head off to school but chief
saliati zuma says every year many girls
drop out and become victims of early
marriage lockdown measures to prevent
the spirit of kova 19 in her community
didn't help
children had nothing to do at home some
got pregnant and got married usually
when girls miss school the teachers tell
us and we found out why but when the
schools close it was hard to keep a
check on them now that schools have
opened we see that some girls aren't in
class
community leaders managed to persuade
these teen mothers to go back to school
one girl says she wants to become a
journalist the others
nurses at first my husband didn't want
me to leave him he ordered me to stay
when the police got involved he got
scared and let me go
now he has found another wife
even before the pandemic malawi had one
of the highest rates of early child and
teenage pregnancy in the world
one out of two girls are getting married
before their age of 18.
then
it definitely is the problem isn't it
almost like a half of the women
population which is 51 percent of the
malawi total population
is becoming
dropping out of school number one and
then secondly becoming a mother before
asia with 18.
teachers say rising poverty could force
more girls out of school and into early
marriages especially
parents they also take part
in those
marriages because they encourage their
children to get knowledge so that they
can have
something to
to earn
from those men
malawi is one of the poorest countries
in the world most of its budget comes
from foreign aid jobs are hard to find
the only real option out here is farming
and there isn't enough work for everyone
some young people will try to get to
south africa to find work there for
those who can't do that getting married
seems to be the only option
the law in malawi forbids marriage for
both boys and girls under 18 but without
proper enforcement it still happens
harumatasa al jazeera mangochi malawi